Selamlar sevgili dostlar. Umarım
iyisinizdir.
E eskiden başlarken sağlık sıat yerinde
mi diye soradım. Onu değiştirip artık
diyorum ki umarım anneniz babanızla
ailenizle güzel zamanlar
geçiriyorsunuzdur.
Eee benim gibi evvelce gidenler de varsa
izleyen onların Allah mekanını rahmet
eylesin. Eee mekanını cennet eylesin.
Kalanların da arkadaşlar bu kod yazılım
serverinde unutmuyoruz. Yanlarına
gidiyoruz. ara ara eee zaman ayırıyoruz
ve onlarla birlikte oluyoruz. Şimdi
bugün arkadaşlar eee birlikte
başladığımız aslında bir seri vardı.
Tabii araya birçok olumsuzluk girdi ama
devam edeceğiz dediğim gibi hayatın
devam etme gerçeğini bildiğim için ne
yazık ki bir yandan da devam edip en
azından burada yine sizlere tanımadığım
ya da böyle uzaktan gördüğüm insanlara
fikir anlatmaya devam edeceğim. Onun
esnadan da arkadaşlar bu refactoring
serimize devam ediyorum. Eee, yine
kanalda ilk geldiyseniz videoya diğer
iki videoya erişebilirsiniz. Analiz
yapmıştık. Pub specleri kontrol
etmiştik. Bugün sizle birlikte aslında
şu üç başlık analiz option, luck, vs
cod. E şimdi arkadaşlar burada aslında
şuraya bir tane daha bir eee package
paket mimarisi de yazayım da şuraya.
Şimdi burada size anlatmak istediğim şey
yine bir flutter projesine girdiniz
diyelim. işte önceden yazılmış işte
benim hazırladığım gibi böyle böyle
hazırlanmış yani bir eski old school
yani bir kodlama var ama bakmanız
gereken yerler daima öncelikli
arkadaşlar eee bizim yapacağımız ya da
dokunacağımız noktalar var. Bunlardan
bir tanesi önceki publ analizde
konuştuğumuz gibi diğeri de bu analiz
option. Özellikle bu analiz option
gerçekten çok çok önemli bir nokta.
Çünkü şöyle bir şey var. Mesela birçok
projeye girdiğimde şöyle bir rule set
görüyorum ve şey geliyor bana ya bu bize
yetiyor. Mesela bunun bir yetme durumu
yok. Şimdi bu analiz option bize neyi
sağlıyor? Kod yazarken bizim yazdığımız
kod to kodların yani yazdığımız
işlemlerin aslında direkt daha kod daha
derlenmeden hemen editörde yani hataları
kontrol edilmesi işte varsa bunların
direkt error atılması ne bileyim işte
boş geçilemez alta inilemez. Bunlarla
ilgili bütün dillerde, frameworkl'lerde
çeşitli toolar, linter hizmetleri
sahnir. Aslında bizim buradaki yaptığım
bir nevi bir linter aslında işlemi
hizmeti. Flutter default zaten bir link
veriyor size ama bu genelde basic ve
yetersizdir. Ondan dolayı birçok aslında
paket var. Bu paketlerden birkaç tanesi
de benim çok sıklıkla kullandığım Vergiz
paketi. Eee, özellikle Vergod Analiz
paketi bence çok tatlı ve güçlü bir
paket. E muadil birçok paket var ama e
coding olarak yaklaşımını ve içeride
aslında birçok kullandığım projedeki
dokunuşu sevdiğim için ben mesela
Vericot analiz paketini kesinlikle
öneriyorum. Biz burada neyi yapıyoruz?
Aslında bir projeye girdik. Projeye
devam edeceğiz. Projeye başlayacağız.
Hurra bak fix atalım değil ya hocam şu
burayı bir düzeltelim. En azından yeni
yazılan kodların devamlılığını sağlama
anlamında buna bakalım dediğimiz için
analiz option yamal'a bakıyoruz. Ve
analiz option yam da burada zaten yine e
size dediğim gibi birçok aslında
linterla alakalı e link toolları var.
Hani benim gördüklerim custom linterlar
işte bir sürü işlemler var ama benim
mesela kullandığım tavsiye ettiğim bu
ama siz de kendinize göre aslında custom
linterlar dahi yazabiliyorsunuz. Şimdi
very good analizi ben eee projeye
tavsiye ettiğim için tabii buraya
kuruyor olacağım. Şuradan alayım bu
projemize biz bunu ekleyelim arkadaşlar.
PUB Speck Yamal'da belki de eklemişizdir
emin değilim. Ha, very good analizi
eklemişiz. Aynen. Bir öncekinde PUSP
konuşurken. Mesela buraya ekledikten
sonrasında burada çeşitli rule açmakla
ilgili kısım var. Zaten hani şöyle bir
şey var. Bunu mesela benim yine çok sık
kullandığım rullardan bir tanesini
alacağım. Diğer projelerimden buraya
getirmiştim. Buraya vereceğim ki buradan
anlatıyor olayım. Hani burayı çünkü tek
tek böyle o bu şu demekten ziyade çünkü
buradaki amacım size bu analiz option
işte ya da buradaki çeşitli şeylerin ne
olduğunu anlatmaktan ziyade aslında size
bu zaten bunların hani refactoring
yapıyorsanız bir şeyi biz şu an burada
refactoring bunları zaten biliyor veya
bu konuyu bilmiyorsanız da araştırmanız
lazım yani an option yal nedir bunlar
nasıl kullanırdan ziyade biz burada daha
efektif yani o mimariyi kurmaya yönelik
hareketler yapıyoruz yani aslında ondan
dolayı bazı kısımlar abi news geçtim
derseniz yani direkt sönmeyin. Buradaki
amacım tamamıyen dediğim gibi toplama ve
bazı basic şeylerin üzerinde çok
durmama. Yani bunu ilk defa görüyorsanız
muhakkak yine kanalda video var ya da
kendinizle araştırabilirsiniz analiz
option daha detaylısını. Şimdi biz
analiz optionda aslında bizim dikkat
etmemiz gereken arkadaşlar iki tane
başta nokta bir analizer bir linter
kısmı. Şimdi linter zaten adı üstünde
linter nedir? Yani bizim projenin ana
hatlarının hangi durumda exception
açacağı işte hangi durumda nelere
bakacağı bakma bak gibi şeyleri
yazacağımız yer. Projenin o coding
seviyesinde bunları anlayacak. Ve
gördüğünüz üzere arkadaşlar yani 5
saniye önceki analiz option yamulla
bu ne ya? Eee 5 saniye önceki analiz
option yamla baktığınız hani şunu
kapatayım bir nevi kapanmıştı. 97 işi
vardı ve hiç exception error yoktu. Ama
sadece bunu eklediğimde bile bir dünya
bakın hemen 412 tane işu geldi. Ve bu
işarın tabii ki bir kısmı info
seviyesinde, bir kısmı şey seviyesinde.
Onu da hızlıca çözeriz. Şimdi eee mesela
burada gördüğünüz gibi buradaki önemli
olan kısım dediğim gibi bir e linker
diğeri de analyzer. Analizer isa bizim
için şöyle önemli. İçerisinde dil
seviyesinde bazı eklemeler
yapabiliyorsunuz. Mesela şurada eee işte
strick bu casleri engellemekle alakalı
işte null event nal geçirmemesi vesaire
alakalı kısımlar. Hatta şuna aslında
gerek yok. Son zamanda zaten bu gelmişti
ama neyse bu oldan gelmiş. Şunu
silebilirim hatta. Şöyle şimdi bu eee
burada önemli olan benim üstte durmak
istediğim aslında exclude etme ve error
kısmı. Şimdi şöyle bir şey var
arkadaşlar. Özellikle exclude edeceğiniz
dosyaları doğru seçmekte fayda var.
Mesela generation dosyaları freeze
kullanıyorsanız ki burada üstünde dur
bilmiyorum. Yine bu generation'ile
alakalı bir işlem. Build dosyaları işte
coverage yapacaksak test coverage
translation mesela e İngilizce Ntr
bunları kullanıyorsanız aslında zaten
bunlar mesela işte çeşitli paketler
tarafından doğrudan projeye eklenip
yapılıyor. Eee Translation'ın
içerisindeki o TRN dosyalarının bir
analize girmesine gerek yok mesela gibi
kendi projenize göre bunları eklerseniz
bu size avantaj veya yer sağlıyor. Yani
hızlı bir şekilde doğru analiz
sağlayacaktır. Şimdi projenin sizeı
büyüdükçe eee yapacağınız işlemler de
otomatik olarak zorluyor projeyi. On ne
kadar doğru exclude ederseniz yani
çıkartırsanız dışarı güzel ama her şeyi
çıkarmamak lazım tabii. O zaman
bozuluyor. E bir de error kısmı önemli
mesela. Mesela ben burada belli başlı
şeyleri çok sevdiğim için mesela missing
error, missing return mesela return
atmadığın yerde bir error atmak lazım.
Eğer return atmak zorundaysa orayı
geçmemek lazım. Yani orası sıkıntılı
yaratabilir. Dead code mesela yine çok
sevmediğim kodda en sevmediğim şeylerden
bir tanesi yani o hani mesela commandli
kod bırakmışsındır bir yerde bir şey
vardır. Bunları engellerim. Mesela
unused import da bence önemli ama
bunlardan diyelim ki hocam ben unused
import'u sevmedim ya. Ben bunu info
seviyesine çekebilirsin. Bu belli başlı
mesela şurada varsa onları kapatacaktır.
E kendine göre bunları
yorumlatabilirsin. Peki Linter'da neler
var? Mesela şu şunu geçeyim. Şunları da
kaldırayım. Mesela burada print mesela
burada print kullanımını işte
kullanmayabilirsin. Bunu bunu kontrol
etme anlamında var. Mesela burada
anacessary kullanımlarda var. Mesela
burada abstraction'la alakalı eklemişti.
Star constinct'la eklemişti. Bunu
bakmadım. Benim mesela en hızlı
yaptıklarımdan bir tanesi public member
API doc'u kapatırım mesela. Yani her
bütün projelerde bu olmuyor. Library
projelerinde buna dikkat ediyorum ama
buralarda olmuyor gibi belli başlı
roları. Mesela ben burada açtım mesela
100 süper parametre. Bunu severim.
Özellikle inheritance yani üstten aşağı
kalıtım yaptığınız, kullandığınız
yerlerde hani süper parametrine paslamak
çok daha hani doğru olduğu için aslında
varsa öyle bir imkan süperine pasla bir
daha bir daha oradan ekleyip oradan
yollama direkt hızlıca yolla gibi. Eee
ondan dolayı mesela bu analiz kısmında
yapacağım işlemin şu andan bile bana
yapar yapmaz yaptığı problem eee
eklediği avantajı görebiliyorsunuz.
Şimdi burada özellikle bir factoring
atarken bunu eklediğinizde projenin
büyüklüğüne göre burada bakın daha basit
bir projede bile birden 300 problem
geldi ya da iş bir şeyler arttıysa büyük
projede ben bunun 16.000 olduğunu gördüm
mesela. 16.000 Ve demedim ki kardeşim bu
iş olmaz. Ve benim en sevmediğim tavır
zaten bu bu uzar. Hiç düşünmeyin. Bu
tarz şeyler bu linterların size
söyledikleri şeyler emin olun ki t
anında hayatınızı kurtaracak şeyler. Sen
unutmuşsundur, exception atmamışsındır,
return atmamışsındır, e çeşitli
parametreleri yanlış paslamışsındır.
Zaten error seviyesinde olanlar hata
verir. Özellikle problemlere gelip
şuradan warningleri ve infoları es
geçerek sadece en azından error
seviyesinde olanları fixlerseniz
hayatınızı kurtarır. Mesela ben buraya
geldiğimde ve şöyle bir şey var bu
arada. Eee mesela
rullar ekledikten sonra formatting
yaptığınızda mesela gördüğünüz gibi ben
onu da size birazdan göstereceğim.
Mesela bende otomatik formatting var.
Bunları yaptığınız zaman arkadaşlar,
eee, projenizde daha efektif bir
aslında, eee, mesela kodu yazarken
otomatik doğru formatlama fixler
çalışıyor. Mesela biz burada şöyle bir
şey yapabiliriz. Backend kısmının bu
projeyle alakası olmadığı için mesela
ben şunu diyebilirim. Ya hocam benim
burada backend'e ihtiyacım yok. Yani ben
şu an backend'i yazdım ama benim ana
hattım ana proje. Onun için mesela
backendi de exclude ettim. Backend kendi
içerisine gitsin çalışsın dediğim için.
Sonrasında mesela buralara geldim.
Buralarda bakın mesela çeşitli hatalar
var. Mesela şurada ben şu an command eee
yani kaydettiğimde fixleyebildiklerini
fixleyecek. Fix fixleyemedikleri. Mesela
bakın burada dedi ki from jon alırken
map kullan. Mesela bunu hep görüyorum
mesela dynamic data hemen tak gelip
buraya işte as map deyip mesela şöyle
ondan sonra bu kursör değil mi ya? K
niye tamamlamadı? Şurayı asmap deyip
şuraya ne istemiş bizden? from Jason
string dynamic mesela şöyle deyip
atılıyor mesela. Mesela bu bir kurtarım
yöntemi değil aslında bakıldığında.
Normalde burada olması gereken mesela
nedir? Dersin ki hocam ben response
datamı aldım. Mesela buraya gelip şey
diyebilirsin. Eee dur mesela dersin ki
final eee response data dersin. Mesela
bunu şöyle yaparsın. Tamam mı? Dersin ki
ben bunu eleyeceğim ama pardon bunu
şurada kest ederken şu şekilde edersin.
Swift tarafına gitti. Sonrasında mesela
bu 200 diye hani şunları düzelteceğiz
zaten refaktör edeceğiz de nal değilse
diye atarsın. Bak buraya gelen data
otomatik olarak artık sen de nal
olmadığını bildiğin ve caste de ihtiyaç
duymadığın hızlıca kontrol edebileceğin
bir işlem olur. Mesela gibi mesela
çeşitli refactoring'leri. Şu an burada
buna çok girmeyeceğim hani çünkü bunun
konsepti bu değil. Bunlar hep burada şu
dynamic callların hepsini yapacağız
aslında. Onu ben bir hani şu an için
analiz option'dan bunu bu kısmını biraz
exclude edebilirim. Bu argument
notessable hepsi zaten ona dönüyor. Buna
döneceğim. Şu argument
şuradan geleyim mesela mesela şu anlık
bunu kapatacağım. Tamam mı? Bu çünkü
bunları çözeceğim bir o refactor
yaparken. Argument neydi onun adı?
type notes.
Eee, şuradan alayım. Copy.
Aa, gelmedi.
Eee, nerede yazıyor? Argument type
necessable not assignable.
Şunu false'a çekersem sanırım şurada.
Hop.
Şöyle yaparsam analiz optionlarının
düşmesini bekliyorum.
Tut tut. Yok. Bunu görmedi. Burada şu
tarafta olabilir mi?
Heh. Argument type nable. Şu anlık bunu
mesela ignore de etmiyorum. Infoya
çekiyorum. Aynen. Errorlardan kaldırdım
şunu. Mesela gibi. Mesela for invalid
valla loop'a mesela yine loop'ta da
böyle bir kullanım olmaz da hani şu an
bunları aldım. Bunu şuraya to olarak
yazıyorum. Yine bir başlıkta bunu şey
yapacağız. Bu printer hatalarını
çözeceğiz. to the fix refactoring zaten
en önemli kalan bir tanesi o. Hatta e
şuraya gelmeden önce kodlere gelmeden
önce e fixed linter rules derim.
Birlikte onları da çözüm çözdürüşüme
bakarız birlikte. Şimdi mesela yani
analiz optionu aslında konseptini
anlamış olduk. Ne yapacağımızı ve
nerelere bakacağımızı, bize neler
getireceğini, şuradakilerin neler
olacağını ve paketlerin third party
paketlerle projeri factorik anlamında
bayağı avantaj getireceğini görüyoruz.
Şimdi biz burada eee
nerede diyor?
E niye olmasın? Ekledim aslında bunu.
Pek yemala gideyim.
Burada var aslında verigut analiz diye.
Verg analizi niye görmedi orada?
Görmüş olması lazım ama dur bakalım. Ben
bunu gördüm.
Include file not found. Bakayım. Very
good analizin dokümantasyonunda
bir değişiklik olmasa gerek.
Eee, deve ekledik. Doğru. Dan include
include ettik.
Hı.
Yok. Burada bir şey olduğunu
düşünmüyorum.
Şeye bakayım bir daha. Vergül tane.
Yook. Burada bir sorun yok. Deve
ekliyorsun zaten. Bu doğru da o niye
görmedi bilmiyorum onu. Neyse o çok
önemli değil. Dev dependisi de var çünkü
bu. Tamam. True. Şimdi arkadaşlar bir
diğer başlığımızı konuşalım yine
hızlıca. Mesela bu luck ignore konusu da
bence önemli bir başlık. Çünkü eee yine
unutulup geç s geçilebiliyor. Şunun
başına 1 yazayım. Şöyle V1 yazayım. Buna
da V2 yapıyorum. Bunların hep V2 olacak.
Şöyle. Ve bu arkadaşlar şimdi bu bizim
zaten flutter projectin default bir git
ignorumuz geliyor. Bundan gen problem
yok ama özellikle iOS düyasında
özellikle gördüğünüz gibi mesela
platform lag dosyaları yine projede
çeşitli dosyalar eee sizin hayatınıza
gelebiliyor. Bu noktada özellikle bizim
şunu yapmamızda fayda var. Bir buradaki
like dosyasını bir kere kafadan hani
bunu ignore atacaksınız. Tamam mı? Bunu
da ignore atarken şöyle yapmakta fayda
yani en basitten bunu sonra historen de
silebilirsiniz. gelirsin. Ben buradan
like dosyasını gördüğümü siliyorum
dersin. Hadi şöyleydi herhalde. Aynen.
Şöyle like dosyasını siliyorum dersin
şuraya. Sonra CD iOS şu mesela ben bunu
önce şöyle yapayım. Bir tane branch
alayım. GCB feature eee analiz
eee
analiz
analiz var. Ignore var.
Bir de neyimiz var şimdi? Bir de oradan
neye bakacakmışız?
Ha, settings.
Settings. Mesela şimdi ben bunu yaptım.
Mesela bunu buraya pushyeayım ben. Şimdi
commit dedim.
Tamam. Şimdi mesela ben şimdi buradan
gelip yine cd iOS deyip buradan pod
install dersem mesela burada dosyamın
tabii şuradan neyini diyor?
Podfilda minimum targeta kızdı. Şöyle
minimum target'ı açalım.
Aslında sıfır proje. Niye kızdı onu?
Belki orada şeyi çekmedik diye olabilir.
Alattım
13 açalım şunu.
Integrate diyelim. Şurada
install diyelim.
Aynen. 13. Muhtemelen paket veya bir
şeyden triggerladı. Tamam. Mesela ben
bunu buraya ekledim. Bu L dosyam niye
yine geldi bana? İsmini mi yanlış
verdik?
Heh. Yook. Tamam. Anlık gözüküyormuş.
Süper. Mesela L dosyasını kaldırım.
Çeşitli logları yine kaldırmanız
gerekiyor burada. Mesela bu Android'de
de arkadaşlar bizim mesela burada
settings, keyjlarımız vesaire oluyor.
Onları da yine lckdos tutmanızda fayda
var. Burada mesela şimdi göstereceğim
log dosyaları ile alakalı olarak tabii
yine projenin bazında çıkartmanız
gereken işte freeze dosyaları mesela
yine burada mesela eee kod yapacağınız
zaman envite da mesela üretilenler var.
Envite'i şöyle yapayım mesela bunu
kullanarak biz de burada yapacağız
diyelim. Mesela buradan envirment
dosyalarını okuyup projeyi import
edeceğiz. environment dosyalarının
okunmaması gerekiyor. Yani çeşitli
dosyaları yine projenin ignoruna
ekleyebilirsin. Burada önemli olan nokta
şu. Bunu zaten eee private projeniz
varsa nasıl dışarıya çıkmayacağını
düşündüğünüz için projenin ignoruna
eklemeden bazı dosyaları tabii ki mesela
K'leri falan bile tutabilirsiniz.
Sonuçta projenin reposunun
içerisindesin. Bunda problem olmaz.
Fakat eee projede doğrudan olacağı için
proje X güini eklersin gider lokaline
çeker ömür boyu lokalinde kalır. Sen K
yollamasan bile on da okey olur gibi.
Bunlara dikkat etmenizde fayda var.
Yoksa sıkıntı yaşanır. Bu sıkıntı
olmaması adına özellikle bu dosyaları da
ignorlarına dikkat etmekte fayda var.
Android'de de özellikle arkadaşlar bu
case settings falan filan burada da
kendi ignorları var ama şurada case
settings dosyaları falan filan
ekleyeceksiniz. release şeyleri
geldiğinde yine o refactoring projesinde
burada onlar yok ama onları geldiğinde
eklemenizde fayda olacak. Eee günün
sonunda doğru dosyaları o ignore nişane
tutarsak o git tarafına özellikle eee
saklanması gereken dosyalardan eee
saklanması gereken dosyaları koymazsak
güzel olur. Ama iyi proje şey büyük yani
privata çok da bazılarını
tutabilirsiniz. Yani çok çok dert
oluşturmayacaktır.
Eee son olarak da burada arkadaşlar
konuşacağımız mesela şu eee VS Code
settings. Mesela bu VS Code settings
gerçekten benim için önemli bir nokta.
Şuradan açayım. Workspace user settings
değil de workspace settings'ten. Şimdi
mesela bu workspace settings'te bunu
açtığınızda mesela bu ignorsuz gelir.
Tamam mı? Siz ignore bunu
ekleyebilirsiniz. Genelde de eklemeniz
önir ama projesine göre ben ortak ses
olması adına ignore eklenmesinde bazen
karşı çıkıyorum. Tamam. Yani aslında
projenin davranışı sizin yapacağınız
hareketlere istinaden
ilerletebilirsiniz. Mesela benim kendi
hazırladığım mesela yine diğer
projelerden aldığım bir basit bir
ignorum var mesela şurada. Tamam mı? Bu
benim için neleri sağlıyor? Burada benim
içerisinde özellikle dart kısmında işte
kod format onon save'lerim var. Mesela
ben bunu eklediğimde biliyorum ki mesela
bir kodla otomatik format atılacaksa
sadece ilgili dosyaları formatlayıp
seviyor. İşte eee ilgili tablere
bakıyor. Editör rullarım var. Yine
format on saveerim var. E burada çeşitli
şu followsın bir keresinde mesela bir
projem çok yavaş açılıyordu. Şu sembol
links'leri follow et mesela işte çözdüm.
Aktif olanın mesela üstünü sarı yapma
gibi yine çeşitli özellikleri açtım.
Burada gösteriyorum. Dediğim gibi ignore
ekleyebilirsiniz ama ben bunu buraya
koyuyorum. Bu nedir biliyor musunuz?
Özellikle büyük projelerde arkadaşlar
projeye göre mesela ben de bazen
eklemediğimiz oluyor şartlar gibi ama
eklemediğimiz projelerde çeşitli
sıkıntılar yaşıyoruz tabii. Ama şöyle
bir şey var. E bu VS COD settings günün
sonunda senin settingsin. Yani ondan
dolayı aslında projenin settingsi olmaz
ya. Buraya gelip çünkü ben burada temayı
değiştirmek isteyebilirim mesela. Yani
ondan dolayı bunu oraya vermek doğru
değil. Ama eee bir akış olması adına ben
buraya koyacağım. Mesela ekiple
çalışırken bunu belirlersiniz. Herkes
kendi lokalinde bunu alır mesela gibi.
Bu da size nevantajı sağlar? İşte projen
ilerledikçe e buraların eee kontrol
edilmesini sağlar. Bir diğer nokta da
mesela mesela launch jonır bizim için.
Mesela bu launch Jonda gelir. Öyle bir
ayarlarsın ki mesela flightbin mesela
burada şu an daha buraları bağlamadık
ama ilerledik diyelim. İlerledikçe
mesela sizin projenin bu projede de
bunlar yaparız. Mesela flightbookin
şuraya şey diyeceğim. Development
development flavor diyeceğim şuna.
Burada buradan gelip mesela şuradan
argüman flutter yok şu argüman değil
miydi bu? Ark aynen mesela argüman
atayıp şuna flavor development
atadığınızda mesela işte bazı durumlarda
çünkü bunlar önemli oluyor. Doğrudan
mesela staging development ortamlarına
geçersiniz. Bu sayede bir daha bir daha
her defasında bunları vermeye gerek
kalmaz. Eee çeşitli durumlarda bunlar
özellikle bu ikisi gerçekten projenin
durumuna ve şartına göre çok avantaj
sağlıyor. Yoksa herkes kendi lokalinde
kafasına göre bir şey yapıyor. Birisi
biliyor diğeri bilmiyor mesela. E bu da
refactoring'ün basit ama önemli
noktalarından başlarken bunları ne kadar
sağ tuttarsanız projede o kadar az gap
yani hata şey gelir. Çünkü bir yani bir
refactor yani refactoring dediğiniz
sadece kod değil çünkü yani kodun
refactoring'i emin olun çok fazla
şekilde yapılabilir. Projesine göre
eklenebilir ama asıl refaktörün kafada
başlar, fikirde başlar. Ondan dolayı
benim burada vermeye çalıştığım o koda
giderken önce o koda gidişat yolunu.
Yani ben bir kod yazdım müthiş ama ekip
işte daha iki tane o printlerde,
return'lerde başka yer patlıyorsa olmaz.
Ekip refactor günü kod refactor tabii ki
ayrı bir kafadır. O da ayrı bir
kalitedir. Ha bu arada şu mesela publ
tabii ki de bunun da mesela bu bunun
ignored olmama şansı yok mesela. Çünkü
artık o proje paket bazıyla onunla
bununla geleceği için her defasında
bununla uğraşacak haliniz yok. Bunun da
gelirsiniz aslında buradan doğrudan
mesela yine şuradan
şuradaki dosya üzerinden nokta lck
dersiniz. Tak bunu burada
commitlersiniz.
Tamam mı? Ondan sonra bir daha karşınıza
onun gelmeyeceğini görürsünüz. Şuradan
şöyle yapayım mesela. Şöyle FPG dedim.
Yaptığımı komitledim.
Şuradan mesela geldim. Hop
rakın da gittiğini gördünüz. Bu sayede
aslında ben en azından yani bu
refctoring'ün bu adımıyla arkadaşlar ben
neleri sağlamış oldum? Kendime eee yarın
herhangi bir şekilde bana bir hani
projede ederken rulların dışına
çıkamayacak. Öyle kafasına göre kod
yazamayacak. Bir yerleri düzeltemeyecek
mesela dynamicleri düzelttiğimizde
dynamic yazamayacak vesaire vesaire.
Bunların hepsini çözmüş olduk ve setting
sation'ımızda fixleri mesela işte nerede
var mesela main dart'a gideyim mesela
diyeyim ki şurada bir fix var mesela
gördünüz mü? otomatik fix atmamızı
sağlayacak o projeye göre. Eee gibi
hareketleri yaparak da burada bir
avantaj sağlamış olduk. Kendimize önemli
olan bir nokta zaten buydu. Eee bunu da
aslında burada sağlamış olduk sevgili
arkadaşlar. Hani bunu da şurada main
artık commitlememe gerek yok. Ya da
commit diyeyim bir şey olmadı. Hadi şura
gelsin.
Eee bunu da burada PR'ın içerisine
ekliyorum. Umarım böyle ufak fikir
dokunuş yapabilmişimdir sevgili
arkadaşlar. Size eee tekrardan şu piyarı
da göstereyim. Burada hazır. Eee,
tekrardan sevgili arkadaşlar ben şöyle
de yapayım. Buradan da bug enhanment
diyelim. Encement şurası hazır zaten.
Ben yine copilot'u kullandığım için
zaten artık herkes bunları aktif olarak
kullanıyor. Şimdi ben burada özellikle
tabii hani bunun üzerinde duracağım. Bu
projelerin sonunda da E kullanımına
yardımcı olmaya çalışıyorum aslında.
Hani bunları yapıyoruz niye yapıyoruz
demiyor. Orada da tartışabilirsiniz. Ben
fikir olarak anlatıyorum. Bunları
aldıkça eminim çok daha iyi promplar,
çok daha iyi fikirler geliştireceksiniz
sevgili arkadaşlar. Tekrardan teşekkür
ediyorum. E ailenizle, sevdiklerinizle
güzel bir zaman geçirmeniz dileğimle.
Bir sonraki içerikte görüşmek üzere
sevgili arkadaşlar. Kendinize iyi bakın.
Yeah.